willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es nachdem wir uns in der letzten
sitzung wo wir uns mit dem bösen befasst
hatten rechts der link zu der sitzung
heute geht es komplementär dazu um das
digitale gute und auch um die politik
der digitalität die gewissermaßen den
rahmen darstellt indem sich das digitale
gute was auch immer das ist
verwirklichen kann und das sind die
fragen wir haben ein paar leitfragen
inwiefern ist die würde des menschen
durch die digitalisierung bedroht das
ist ein riesenthema ziehen sich an das
thema privatsphäre mache ich auch oben
rechts links
da ändert sich was bezüglich der
informationen die uns als individuen
betreffen
dann die frage wie können wir die würde
des menschen durch die digitalisierung
schützen
das ist eine spannende frage also nicht
nur in der digitalisierung was passiert
gar mit der würde und wie können wir sie
auch durch die digitalisierung
schützen
vielleicht auch vergrößern das ist auch
nicht vorher kann man die würde
vergrößern müssen manchmal fragen
liefern kann es noch ein recht auf nicht
wissen im digitalen raum geben das
problem ist hier dass wir können durch
das internet durch die freie
verfügbarkeit von informationen die auch
häufig als ein neues menschenrechte
gefordert wird dadurch können wir sehr
viel wissen die frage ist ob das wissen
ist wenn sie nur informationen ist ich
sage mal informationen beziehen
informationen können ja wahr oder falsch
seien information das sind wie wir
gesehen haben ja nur aussagen der form
dass
das jemand die überzeugung hat oder
vorgibt dass etwas der fall ist das ist
eine information und insofern würde ich
hier statt dem recht auf nichtwissen
informationen sprechen
und wir sehen eben durch die vernetzung
wird der zugang zu informationen immer
leichter und dann stellt sich die frage
wie können wir ware von falschen
informationen unterscheiden wie können
wir wissen erlangen und inwiefern haben
wir eine pflicht dann auch im internet
etwas zu wissen also vielleicht auch
informationen kritisch zu überprüfen
hier hat sie einiges verändert die aus
medialer hinsicht die nächste frage in
wie vielen sollten wir eine recht haben
nicht objekt von automatisierten
entscheidungsverfahren zu werden diese
leitfragen beziehen sich auf die
digitale karte die ein projekt darstellt
zur
digitalisierung im internet die stelle
ich ihnen gleich vor das ist so eines
dieser eine dieser forderung dieser
digitalen karte automatisierte
entscheidungsverfahren können natürlich
mit künstliche intelligenz
zusammenhängen und dann die frage die
wir uns auch vorgenommen haben worin
könnte das digitale gute bestehenden die
jetzt schon gesehen haben der letzten
sitzung was das digitale böse das
künstliche böse ist was ist das digitale
gut und wie können wir es digital
vergrößern
wir wählen es gibt eine digitale karte
www.digital digital charta punkt eu die
charta der digitalen grundrechte der
europäischen union die fordert digitale
grundrechte können sie mal drauf ging
hier finden sie einige artikel davor
aber noch
eine vorwort erklärung die weitere
information gibt und hier ist etwa
wichtig ist die rede von neuen
herausforderungen
diese entstehen durch neue formen der
automatisierung vernetzung künstliche
intelligenz vorhersage und steuerung
menschlichen verhaltens ersten
überwachung robotik und mensch maschine
interaktion machtkonzentration bei
staatlichen nichtstaatlichen akteuren
das ist eine problematik aus politischer
sicht und hiervon geht jetzt die
digitale karte einige artikel die die
grundrechte betreffen
interessant ist dabei können sie mal
darauf gelegt dass hier auch immer eine
diskussion möglich ist der jeweiligen
artikel
hier gibt es eine prämie
natürlich muss auch die würde in
digitalen zeiten
geschützt werden der menschen
sieht ohne bezeugt dass die zunehmende
digitalisierung zur veränderung der
grundlagen unserer existenz führt
machtverschiebungen zwischen dem
einzelnen staat und unternehmen
das ist ganz wichtig waren gesehen große
unternehmen dominieren auch die
verfügbarkeit von
digitalen möglichkeiten
also hier soll freiheit gerechtigkeit
und solidarität im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert erhalten werden das ist die
zielsetzung dieser digitalen karte
das 5
ordnung digitalen zeitalters soll
geschaffen werden das digitale sei nicht
als quelle der angst sind als chance für
ein gutes leben einer globalen zukunft
gefasst werden dem ist sicherlich nur
zuzustimmen die frage ist nur wie soll
man ist machen und jetzt diskutieren wir
und auch diese
vertreterin vertreter dieser digitalen
karte verschiedene artikel artikel eins
lautet die würde des menschen ist auch
im digitalen zeitalter unantastbar sie
zu achten und zu schützen ist das
pflicht keine technische entwicklung
darf sie beeinträchtigen es gibt es hier
natürlich auch der diskussionsseite
können sie mal schauen was sich der
kommentar ich vermute mal das ist zeugen
das betrifft die frage müssen muss im
digitalen raum
und unter klarnamen
immer kommentiert werden ich glaube dass
es schon eine kultur der anonymität gibt
ein gewisser jürgen plümer sagt es gibt
ein vergleich zur formulierung der
menschenwürde im grundgesetz und er sagt
geht digital charta formulierung
gestellt im zweiten satz einen
rückschritt dar da hier die
begrifflichkeit der verpflichtung fehlt
ja die staatliche gewalt sei nach dem
grundgesetz die menschliche würde achten
und hier ist jetzt keine verpflichtung
unterhalt nur sie ist zu achten das ist
ja auch eine verpflichtung von der
formulierung her schauen sie mal sie
interessant sie können natürlich auch
mitdiskutieren artikel 2 freiheit jeder
mensch hat ein recht auf freie
information kommunikation
es beinhaltet das persönliche recht auf
nichtwissen das ist jetzt die
entscheidende frage
das recht digitalen raum etwas nicht zu
wissen oder
sollten wir vielleicht gerade deswegen
auch eine pflicht haben zu wissen und
luciano fluri dem sie schon kennen
gelernt haben der letzten sitzung der
schreibt ihr leben eine substanzielle
ausführung des rechts auf nichtwissen
einer immer reibungslose funktionieren
infos fähre verliert die behauptung man
habe nichts gewusst
angesichts von leicht vorhersehbaren
ereignissen und kaum ignorieren fakten
zunehmend an glaubwürdigkeit
genau die gegenthese
darüber werden wir auch nachher
diskutieren gibt es ein recht auf
nichtwissen und auf informationsfreiheit
man muss sich immer fragen woher könnte
das recht oder die pflicht stammen
wir haben hier noch einen artikel der
einem weiteren thema der gleichheit
gewidmet ist jeder mensch hat das recht
auf eine gleichberechtigte teilhabe in
der digitalen sphäre
ja digitale sphäre was ist das
was ist genau durch digitale sphäre hier
zu verstehen das ist ja gar nicht klar
ziemlich vage sphäre wenn man so schon
redet nicht ganz klar so ein kritikpunkt
von mir im zentrale begriffe sind in
dieser charta philosophisch nicht
geklärt eine digitale ethik oder auch
eine digitale politik muss jedoch
zunächst die grundbegriffe und ihren
gegenstand klären also hier werde ich
dann auch mal darunter was schreiben als
diskussionsbeitrag
und dass man ihren natürlich
konstruktive also müsste erst überhaupt
mal definieren was eine digitale sphäre
ist unser angebot in diesem seminar wäre
ein virtueller handlungsraum da wird
nämlich schon klar dass wir da nicht nur
informationen beziehen oder austauschen
und dass das eine handlung ist dir
verziehen gerade auch wenn neue formen
des internets wie des metalls und jetzt
immer präsenter werden
digitale sphäre erweckt den eindruck es
handele sich nur um ein irgendwie
geartetes schein gebilde eine höhere
sphären
dabei ist doch die digitalisierung was
ganz lebensweltlich reals thema
virtuelle realität
dann haben wir hier noch einen weiteren
artikel der die privatsphäre die
vertraulichkeit datenschutz anbelangt da
haben wir auch schon darüber diskutiert
in einer sitzung dann mache ich auch
oben rechts und links jeder mensch hat
das recht auf den schutz seiner daten
und die achtung seiner privatsphäre
personenbezogene daten dürfen nach treu
und glauben für festgelegte zwecke beim
betroffenen erhoben verarbeitet werden
wenn hierfür eine gesetzliche grundlage
besteht die datenverarbeitung sicher
fair transparent und nach dem stand der
technik gestaltet werden rechte auf
löschen berichtigung widerspruch
informationen aus sind zu gewährleisten
und jetzt kommt der entscheidende punkt
der mich persönlich sehr interessiert
jeder mensch hat das recht auf digitalen
neuanfang dieses recht findet seine
grenzen in den berechtigten
informationsinteresse der öffentlichkeit
ein digitaler neuanfang das klingt jetzt
wie ein neues leben ein neuer lebens
beginn ein reboot sozusagen
das setzt voraus und hier implizit
jedenfalls dass im digitalen virtuellen
handlungsrahmen auch ein gewisses leben
möglich ist und dass man hier neue
starten können müsste damit ist
natürlich gemeint dass informationen die
für uns mal im internet gelandet sind
das die auch wieder entfernt werden
müssen
natürlich ist hier der digitale
neuanfangs begriff noch völlig unklar
müsste dann auch genauer noch bestimmen
und genau das sagt auch eine leerung man
im kommentar ich würde es gut finden
wenn der begriff digitale neuanfang
genauer definiert werden wie genau kann
man den neu anfangen wie wird garantiert
dass persönliche daten wirklich was
inhalt gelöscht wird das haben wir auch
diskutiert zum thema anonymität
datenschutz ja also wir müssen wichtige
begriffe ist man noch ein bisschen
genauer geklärt werden auch die achtung
der privatsphäre was genau bedeutet dass
ne hier sind wir philosophin philosophen
aber auch andré geisteswissenschaftlerin
und geisteswissenschaftler gefragt
artikel 10 freier zugang jeder mensch
hat das recht auf einen freien und
gleichen zugang zu kommunikations- und
informationsdiensten ohne dafür auf
grundlegende rechte verzichten zu müssen
dieser zugang ist flächendeckend
angemessen und ausreichend zu
gewährleisten jeder mensch hat das recht
auf eine nicht personalisierte nutzung
digitaler angebote
einschränkungen dürfen nur aufgesetzt
und lage stattfinden das ist wichtig die
digitalen angeboten sollten
nicht personalisierte also nicht
kommerzialisiert primär sein also wir es
heute nicht im virtuellen handlungsraum
zu bloßen objekten von kommerziellen
interessen werden
natürlich muss jetzt auch das begriffe
begriff digitales angebot genauer
erklärt werden hier liegt es nahe dass
das internet nur als konsum medium als
angebots medien betrachtet wird wir
sollten davon wegkommen meinen augen und
ist nicht nur als ein konsums und als
ein handlungs medium verstehen dass
nämlich verhindert dass wir zu bloßen
objekten werden wenn wir nur konsumenten
und objekte im konsum medium internet
sind dann findet eine für
gegenständliche sehr schnell statt wenn
wir hingegen akteurin war akteure sind
dann wird es viel schwerer uns zu
objektivieren bei bürger darin immer in
bewegung sind ganz entziehen können der
gegenständliche das wäre so ein plädoyer
da kann man fleißig mitdiskutieren ich
glaube das hilft auch diesen der
stellerin herstellern dieser digitalen
karte gibt es ein onlive manifest
führung von luciano flori denn sie schon
kennen gelernt haben der hat dieses
online manifest was sie open access
beziehen könnte ich nach unten dann in
der beschreibung ein link zu diesem buch
hinein dieses buch hat den untertitel b
mit jungen in hyper connected er über
connected finde ich sehr spannend hier
sieht man die welt die maus datenpunkten
besteht und wir sollen darin noch
menschlich sein
[Musik]
er schreibt die entwicklung
beeinträchtigt das die menschliche
kondition die conditio humana
sie verändert die verhältnisse zu uns
selbst um zu der welt
und er macht hier folgende
transformationen
ausfindig die unterscheidung von
realität und virtualität wird schlimmen
die unterscheidung zwischen mensch
maschine und natur wird schwimmend und
es gibt jetzt ein informationsüberfluss
es gibt einen
shift eine übergang von dingen zu dem
vorrang der dinge der substanzen der
einst dinge das betrifft die unterlage
zum vorrang der interaktionen es geht
also nicht mehr um die einzelnen zu um
die relationen in denen diese dinge
zueinander stehen das finde ich auch
ziemlich treffend für die neueren
entwicklungen
man möchte in diesem manifest eine
debatte in dem eröffnen sie ihren
die eben auf diese hyper connect für
hyper verbundene welt reflektiert
und erfordert dass wir eine digital
gebildete gesellschaft
werden die die solidarität in das führt
dann auch zum thema aufklärung der
digitalität mit der wir mit dem wir in
den nächsten 17 zu tun haben wird er
spricht hier also von der utopie des al
wissens
in diesen neuen medien ich gehe jetzt
nicht mehr darauf ein das lohnt sich
wirklich mal versicht nachzulesen
digitale bildung ist ein riesenthema
und ich habe schon angedeutet
digitale bildung führt zur frage was ist
digitale aufklärung das wird das thema
der nächsten sitzung sein hier geht es
um die folge erstmalig gefahren
existieren überhaupt die uns eine solche
aufklärung erst
als notwendiges thema erscheinen lassen
das heißt es geht auch um die digitale
unmündigkeit und sie erinnern sich alle
immanuel kant hat gesagt aufklärung ist
der ausgang aus der selbstverschuldeten
unmündigkeit
das heißt wir müssen erst untersuchen
bevor wir die frage klären was digitale
aufklärung ist was eine digitale
unmöglichkeit ist hier gibt es
verschiedene formen der digitalen
mündigkeit wie zum beispiel
lose virtuelle welten im sinne der
bloßen simulation fake news der haben
darüber diskutiert und dann stellt sich
die frage wie können wir aus dieser
unmündigkeit uns selbst befreien darüber
wird es den nächsten sitzer kleiner ja
dann bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit
und
wünschen noch eine schöne woche bis zur
nächsten sitzung